got a side hustle called Pony up it's a
free to play sports pick a map just
launched last month good for you I'm a
one-man band One Man Band don't really
feel the stands so if you were me one
man Ben stooped on the stands well they
do they just take a long time to fill
the stance yeah that's fair if I were
you what would you be focusing on right
now Tick Tock creative because one piece
of content can go viral at a higher
percentage than any other platform we've
seen in 15 years and that may be the
Gateway if you have your email in your
profile and your url that may lead to
the person that needs to see it reach
out to you and Away you go okay awesome
I lived this game when I was a one-man
band for six years making content when
nobody gave a [ __ ] yeah and couldn't go
as viral as one piece of content on Tick
Tock yeah you have a good nice nice no I
appreciate that this is the greatest era
to be a one-man band ever that's fair
that's fair let's change the mindset I
appreciate that I'm like a hallway
camera it is a mindset thing yeah always
always
awesome man I appreciate it it's content
content it's always content